And now we have the amazing car out East man who was running for Congress, Adam,
Nebraska, second district, which I think includes Omaha. That's right, right.
Welcome. Carl. Welcome. Welcome to yang speaks.
You and I met when I was campaigning in Iowa. Um,
because for those of you who aren't geographical experts, Iowa,
Nebraska touch each other, like right there.
Yes. And I said this then, and I,
you were the most inspiring political speaker I'd ever heard talk.
So thank you for that. It was, it was fun and, you know, politics,
isn't always that much fun.
Politics is not that much fun, but you've been in the change-making, uh,
line of work for a long time. Um,
you and I bonded over the fact that you also started and ran a nonprofit that
did incredible work in your case. It was a, uh,
children's nonprofit based in Nebraska.
Yep. I was called Omaha healthy kids Alliance. It's still exists,
but I no longer there. I was hired to start it in 2006.
And our focus was, uh, originally was eliminating childhood lead poisoning.
And that eventually we grew into a green and healthy housing organization.
Well,
your evolution is similar to mine in that you run a nonprofit and you see all
these problems, uh, in our community is, and you think, wow,
someone should really do something about that. And then you're like,
I guess it might be me because after you
work, uh, as a nonprofit leader, you kind of get a sense as to, uh,
frankly like the need for different solutions to solve the problems you're
tackling every day.
That's right. Well, and,
and these are problems that can be fixed if we have,
cause we have the resources to fix them in this country.
We just don't have the political will.
Yeah. Well, you're changing that.
Tell us about your race in Nebraska for people who don't know that much about
it. And also, and you can do this in order. Um,
when did you first hear about universal basic income?
Well, um, I heard about it from you on the campaign trail,
so there's that, but um, yeah, it's,
it's an exciting race here in the second district.
All eyes are on us because in 2008, uh,
we gave an electoral college vote to Barack Obama in Nebraska.
We split our electoral college votes similar to Maine.
And so we have that one that some people are saying could be the deciding
electoral college votes, a little terrifying to think about,
but could be true and Biden is ahead in the polls and as am I.
And so we have a real opportunity to elect the first woman to serve the
district. Uh, somebody I'm running against a Trump Republican,
who's voted with him 93% of the time.
And also to give that electoral college vote to get rid of Trump.
Well, you are up, it is very hard to beat an incumbent. Tell us more like it,
it sounds like has this guy been in Congress for a long time?
He's in his second term. And you know,
I th I actually ran him in 2018 and came up
1.9% short in one of the closest races in the country.
So we're back again and we've given people four years to see him in action and
he's betrayed the district over and over again.
And they're looking for somebody who's actually going to represent them.
Wow, you're going to make that, that the comeback it's like car, the return,
you know, like Rocky too, a little bit like,
like the first race was Rocky one,
we all know what happens at the end of Rocky.
Two Rocky wins for those of you who haven't seen it yet.
Uh, one reason why I'm thrilled to get you into Congress is that, uh,
you are for cash relief during the pandemic and someone who's worked with
families the way you have, um,
you would be for casually because you understand the good it would do, uh,
in the lives of so many people in your district.
That's right.
We have so many politicians in office in
particular on the Republican side who do not seem to understand the
needs of regular working people. And that, you know,
most of us are one economic shortfall away from
total bankruptcy, total annihilation of our family.
And if that's in the form of hitting a pothole and having your tires blow out,
when you haven't, you don't have the money saved up to actually pay for that,
which is challenging to do because it's expensive or getting laid off from your
job.
And now we see this in the middle of the pandemic where so many people have lost
their job and therefore lost their healthcare. So it's,
we need people in Congress who understand this.
We need more working class people in Congress.
The average net worth of a congressperson right now is a million dollars.
We need people who understand this stuff.
And I've had the honor of working in nonprofit organizations for over 20 years.
My worldview is framed by the clients that I've had the honor of serving,
and I believe they deserve a voice.
So tell us about your race. I mean,
you came within a hair's breadth of winning in 2018.
And what are you seeing this time?
We're seeing a lot of change with independence in the district about a quarter
of the district are registered independence.
We started our campaign this time by knocking doors of independence in 2018,
we knocked on 200,000 doors around the entire district.
And so, um,
and what we heard from independence this time was their number one priority was
getting Donald Trump out of office.
So when we have a congressperson who has so heavily aligned himself with Trump
and with the Republican party, Nebraskans are pretty independent,
but we have a unicameral we've had, uh,
we've actually been a primary progressive state in the past where we had
Democrats as our governor, as our us senators. And,
and I think a lot of people have seen that the Trump administration's failed
promises have actually really hurt Nebraska,
especially in terms of our agricultural economy.
And especially in terms of that tax bill,
which we know was not for regular working people.
I agree with you that independence right now are looking up and saying,
we got to turn the page for our country. Trump has to leave.
And I think that's one reason why I am so pumped about your race and
other races around the country that, uh, you have a wind at your back. Uh,
this time that I don't think has existed in my recent memory.
Um, so we need to get behind candidates like you and make sure that you,
you went.
I agree. Well, and when we look at 2018 people talk about, you know,
the fact that it was great that we flipped the house, but you know,
84% of incumbent Republicans in the house kept their seat.
So I would not describe that as a blue wave,
but I think that we can have that this time expanding the house majority,
flipping the Senate, and obviously flipping the presidency.
Uh, the, the I'm optimistic about, uh, your race in many other races, cars.
I think the toughest thing is going to be after you all get to Congress is
trying to get that institution working, um, more efficiently and effectively,
uh, than it has been, uh, in quite some time.
But it starts with getting people like you in having a non-profit leader like
you, uh, who is so close to your community, um,
in Congress trying to craft policy would be such a quantum leap
forward. Uh, and it is funny, like talking to you now,
I think other people might have the same impression, um, because like you said,
most members of Congress at this point are, uh, very affluent. Uh, you know,
a lot of them come from, uh, business backgrounds and,
uh, backgrounds where they can plug into like a network of money. Um,
and you come from a very different background. It's very,
very grassroots driven. Uh,
the fact that a candidate like you is poised to make a bit of history, uh,
political history. It sounds like in Nebraska, uh,
is such a great sign for 2020. Um,
what would your top legislative priorities be after you get sworn in because
you're going to win and you're going to get sworn in 20 times.
Aside from, you know,
dealing with the pandemic in a responsible way that actually demonstrates
leadership and prevents human lives from being lost. Uh,
my two priorities are healthcare fixing our broken healthcare system.
We're going to S we have to start with Loring prescriptions.
I'm running because my mother was prescribed a $2,500 pill that she couldn't
afford to take. And I want to get money out of politics.
So actually fighting corruption and reforming our system and
doing things to stop the threats to our democracy.
I think that that's incredibly important probably now more than ever.
So many people agree with you on those priorities. I love them.
It's a economic or a leaf fixing our healthcare system and getting money out of
politics slash tying our politics that people, uh, my proposal, as you know,
was give everyone a hundred democracy dollars. Um,
so the goal will be to wash the corporate money out.
So it's not even quite get the money out of politics. It's more like tie the,
to what ordinary people think. Um,
because right now the number of people that donate to political campaigns,
and if you're someone who's donated to a campaign,
you should know that puts you in, like the,
like maybe 10% of Americans donate to political campaigns.
It's probably risen this cycle. So let's call it 1214, but that's still, um,
highly unusual.
So what can we get that percentage up to if everyone had a hundred thousand
dollars and then they said, I like Carra Eastman. You know, I'm going to,
I'm going to get behind her and I've got a hundred democracy dollars to do. So,
like, what percentage do you think we'd get up to if everyone had a hundred free
dollars.
Upwards of 80%? I mean,
I think people would actually get engaged and get involved. And,
and one of the things that,
that struck me and I don't ever hear anyone talking about this,
so maybe we could, but when I first started running, you know, they tell you,
like go to your friends and family, ask for money. Right. I did that. Like, I,
my friends gave me $50. It's wonderful. Yeah. But like,
what they mean is go to your wealthy friends and family and go to corporate
packs. But when I started looking at the lists of people who donate to Democrats
in our district,
99.9% of those people were white people.
And it was shocking to me that we have so few people of color who give to
political campaigns. So, so drill down that number even more. Right. And,
and we know, especially for wealthier donors,
they often get prioritized in my campaign. We, we run on a grassroots campaign.
Our average donation is incredibly low. We have thousands of donors,
but that's not typical.
This is actually pretty different for a district like mine and just different in
general,
because it's not just Republicans that have done this it's Democrats as well.
So we need to change the system.
Yeah. The numbers are very, very, um, damning in this regard.
So I said, let's say 10% of Americans donate.
And those 10% are donating 50 bucks. Cause that's what a normal person would do.
If you drill down to people who donate over $250,
which makes you like a more serious donor that 10% drops quickly to like,
I think it's 1%. So, uh,
and you're looking at the top, uh,
10th of 1% that give like the max of 2,800, um,
in a, in a federal race. Uh, and so when you were given fun fundraising,
uh, direction about running for Congress,
you need to raise 1.6 million on average to be successful. Uh,
and so if you do the math on that, like, uh, it's hard to get there on like,
like 20 bucks. Uh, you know, you need like a lot of people.
So they expect you to go chase down the folks who can give you thousands. Uh,
and that's the game and we need to change the game so that you have more
representatives that actually answered, uh, uh,
people that aren't in position to give thousands of dollars.
That's right. And you don't,
we shouldn't have candidates or elected officials spending time doing this.
This is not how, I mean,
you don't want your congressperson spending six hours a day raising money. Well,
you don't want that. But unfortunately it's.
The norm, uh,
Lawrence Lessig cited a study that said that members of Congress been 30 to 70%
of their work hours raising money. So that's six hours a day.
That's not an exaggeration, that's not a car. I'm just making it up. I mean,
that's real. Uh, so Kara people want to get behind you and help, uh,
push you to victory. Uh, on November 3rd, uh, working, they,
they find out about you and how can they help.
Uh, Eastman for congress.com on Twitter at Kara, for Congress car,
with a K Facebook at Eastman for Congress or Instagram at Khara for Congress.
And we can use all the help. We need money. We need volunteers.
We need people just to spread the word on social media,
whatever you can do right now.
The value that gets generated.
And the last number of days is like a lot of things in life,
or like a lot of the last mile value is the most important.
So it's not too late to help. Carra, uh, Kara Eastman,
Nebraska, second district give help volunteer text bank, phone bank,
and we're going to be in position to celebrate car's victory.
You're going to be such an incredible member of Congress and I am pumped for it.
I'm pumped to be a part of it.
Thank you. That means a lot coming from you. I appreciate it.
Oh, appreciate you, Carl. Let's win. Thank you for listening in.
I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did, please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know every time we haven't
yet.